it's been 100 earth years since you
settled on mars you've been through pain
loneliness and
a lot of hard work
and now mars is the new promised land
everyone dreams of
but
how did you get there
how would you find clean water and air
on mars
what would you have to do to make mars
self-sufficient
and how long before everyone can afford
to travel to mars
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you spent 100 years on mars
it all started when spacex founder elon
musk imagined that 1 million people
could be living on mars within 100 years
i reinvented electric cars and i'm
sending people to mars in a rocket ship
well mars has been a worthy contender
for planet b since 1960 when uncrewed
missions began
it's got the same day rhythm as earth
and carbon dioxide for plants to do
photosynthesis
mars has 38 percent of earth's gravity
and one percent of its air density it
gets 44 percent as much sunlight as
earth
these wouldn't be the conditions you're
used to but
it would be a start
so you packed up and got yourself a job
on the first base on mars and not just
any job
you would be the first person to set
foot on the red planet 100 years in
what milestones of civilization would
you see
to go on this dangerous interplanetary
voyage you'd need to be an astronaut
you'd spend years in training before you
could even board the shuttle but you
made it
and now it would be you versus mars
you'd land in the surroundings of the
gizero crater that's where the
perseverance rover touched down in 2021
to check out the territory before your
arrival
you'd be doing some research and
reporting back to earth
the connection wouldn't be great
you'd have to wait up to 22 minutes for
communication signals to get to earth
eventually you'd witness the first cargo
ships arriving with supplies
a few years after your arrival the first
batch of settlers would appear
everything they'd need would be varied
from earth it would cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to feed each person
so
you'd need to start thinking about how
to make the settlement
self-sufficient first order of business
water the settlers would start the
mining of water ice near the base
you would see the first human base set
up on mars it would be named mars base
alpha just like elon musk wanted
you and 170 other astronauts would live
there
robots would be taking care of the
initial prospecting and construction it
would no longer take 20 minutes to
receive communication signals from earth
that's because your settlement would set
up two constellations of starlink
satellites orbiting mars
more people would arrive from earth
another base would be underway and
finally the very first child would be
born on mars
but could this martian child ever visit
earth
how would their bones and organs survive
in earth's gravity
[Music]
maybe they should stay on mars
you know it's possible that parents of
kids born on the red planet could get
better financial support from their
local martian government than what's
available for some kids on earth now
imagine if the government of mars gave
parents or legal guardians thirty six
hundred dollars every month to help
raise children up to five years of age
and after that three thousand dollars a
month until the day they turn 18.
don't you think that would improve a
kid's chance in life offer them more
freedom more support give them financial
independence in the future and then
wouldn't this improve martian society in
general
parents wouldn't have to work so hard in
the martian mines to try and make enough
to sustain their family
everybody would have a better life
you know it's my hope that one day we'll
all get a better future here on earth
but that starts with larger efforts like
the transition away from fossil fuels
and reducing carbon emissions supporting
small businesses and creating fairer
societies through things like the child
tax credit
but back to your martian adventure
mars base alpha would become a
full-fledged settlement you would see
many more firsts the first school the
first cultured meat farm and even the
first luxury hotel public transport
would connect base alpha to mining sites
every few years ships would arrive each
carrying 100 passengers
the settlement would begin building its
first dome city
it would be a 1.6 kilometer wide impact
crater covered by a transparent
radiation filtering dome
it would need earth-like pressure and
temperatures so the settlers could
finally take off their spacesuits
at this point the population of mars
would reach 200 000
with advanced medical technology your
life expectancy would increase
you would finally be able to visit your
friends back on earth
it wouldn't be so easy for those born on
mars
they would need to use exoskeletons to
survive earth's heavier gravity
wealthy people from earth would come to
mars on vacation
an artificial magnetic field generator
would permanently protect the martian
atmosphere from space radiation
mars would now have five dome cities
the largest among them mars city would
be home to sixty thousand people soon
the first elected city council would
take office and the first university
would open
one million people would permanently
live on mars
you and your fellow settlers would be on
pace to terraform the planet
you would release controlled amounts of
greenhouse gases to thicken the
atmosphere and cause the temperature to
increase
you accelerate the process by
establishing fish farms and releasing
cyanobacteria that would start
photosynthesis there would be a rising
tide for independence in martian cities
martians might not be too keen on
staying controlled by the earthlings
after all they'd have 100 years of
history to be proud of
mars base alpha would become a national
heritage site and hyperloops and
sub-orbital shuttles would connect major
martian cities
eventually the dream of terraforming
would come true fresh water would flow
in the once lifeless martian surface and
settlers would finally be able to
breathe in lungs full of fresh martian
air
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]